meet yourself and say hi
hi hi everyone
hey uh
you're a little quiet maybe we can can
we get very excited
um
sorry is this better yeah that's
noticeably better
headphones have been through the wash
one too many times
okay
um
okay is this okay so i can't i can't see
you but if there are questions then
please um
uh
you know please uh please scream yeah
yeah we actually have a better mic that
i will run over people who have
questions
okay okay
um
okay you won't have your slides yet
oh sorry you don't you don't see them no
we do not
[Music]
is this working
yeah now we're there okay perfect
um
okay
uh
we have greg valiant from stanford on
charting the landscape of memory data
trails and continuous optimization take
it away greg
okay well yeah thank thanks so much for
inviting me and yeah sorry sorry i
couldn't be there today um
so
i guess i'll talk about a few things um
and i've been thinking about these sorts
of questions with um annie marsden who's
a phd student um
uh vatsala charon who
was a phd student i guess and just
started uh
his faculty job at usc and um and and
and so rather than
telling you about specific kind of
technical
details of any one result i wanted to
give the sort of bird's eye view of the
landscape with a sort of emphasis on
some of the open uh questions
so everything in this talk should be
understand
you know should be understood by
everybody
in the room who
who wants to understand it so stop me if
that's not the case
good so the basic question
is how do
constraints on the amount of memory that
an algorithm has
influenced the amount of
data or the convergence rates
for sort of fundamental learning or
optimization customers
and i guess today um since it'll be
helpful to have a very concrete uh sort
of problem in mind um we'll focus on
just linear regression um or maybe more
uh
even more specifically just solving
a system of linear equations
and most of what we say will extend to
um
you know to larger families of learning
problems or
more general convex optimization but
let's let's focus on this one uh
specific question
and there are two the twos are different
models in which you can ask these
questions about how memory influences um
the speed of learning
so one is the setting of um where you
have access to independent data samples
and the other setting is a cell phone
model
so
in this first setting where you have
access to independent data samples
the problem will be formulated in terms
of some distribution over
um over data points so here maybe a pair
a b
where a is some vector and b is some
real valued label so maybe a is chosen
according to some d-dimensional gaussian
and maybe b is the inner product of a
with some mystery vector x and the goal
will be to learn x
and
here we think of an algorithm with
bounded memory as well it has the modest
amount of rewrite memory and whenever it
wants it can say give me a new data
point and this data point is going to be
drawn according to this specified
distribution
on the other hand the cell probe model
um
is
similar but here the examples are going
to sit in some possibly quite large
read-only memory so there's some
read-only memory full of uh data points
and again the algorithm will have some
access to a modest amount of read write
memory
and whenever the algorithm wants uh you
know to to get some data it just needs
to query this read-only menu so it'll
say you know what's the 30-second uh you
know bit in the 75th data example and so
on
and within the cell pro model there are
different variants so some sometimes you
can probe individual
elements of each data point sometimes
you sort of ask for the whole data point
um but by and large uh
um the kind of different variants within
the cell pro model basically um
aren't so different
so these are two different models of um
in which you can start asking these
questions about learning with found in
them
so um beyond these two models there are
two different two very different
settings that we might want to think
about so one is a discrete setting
for example where we're trying to solve
some system of linear equations over say
a finite field
and the other is a continuous setting
where we're doing
we're solving some linear system over
the reals or we're doing regression or
some more general convex optimization
so i wanted to give um
a specific so specific problems for each
of these four uh boxes at least so we um
have a very concrete sense of what we're
talking about
okay so in this setting where we're
given sort of independent data samples
um in the discrete setting
um one sort of very natural and standard
problem one might think about is the
question of learning a parity
so the universe has selected
a length d
binary vector x
and say it's chosen uniformly random
from the set of
lengthy binary vectors
and then each data point
um consists of a lengthy uniformly
random binary string
together with a label which is going to
be the inner product of this uh you know
this vector a i with the secret vector x
inner products are taken mod 2.
and the goal is going to be to find x
so you can think about this as there's a
random linear system over f2 and you're
given examples you know consistent with
this
linear system
so the analogous problem in the cell
probe setting um
you know it's really the the same
problem except here
the data points these ai comma the inner
product fan and x mod 2 are given in
some read-only matrix
and you know they can be accessed on
demand
and you could think of this cell pro
model setting where you have maybe
you know on the order of n data sorry on
the order of d data points maybe you
could think about it
in the setting where you have on the
order of d square data points or maybe
you can think about it as
there's kind of a
infinite number of data points and
whichever ones you want to look at you
can look
great can i just ask a question
in this cell problem model so does this
mean that you can choose which a
you want to look at uh
no um so there is a matrix in which
maybe these a's have been filled in at
random
but then you can specify in terms of the
indices of this matrix which elements to
read
so the universe has has filled this
read-only memory with random examples
like from this distribution and then you
can say you know give me the first bit
of the first example give me the eighth
bit of the twelfth example
but you know this means that you can
come back again yes yes so
so it doesn't disappear if you need the
memory
okay exactly exactly so uh
yeah so so great the the main difference
between these two
models
instead in some sense the only
difference between them
is that in the cell probe model if you
want to go back
and look at the first example again
you just ask for it again
in the
sort of you know iid data
model
the only way you can go back and see the
first example again is if you use your
precious memory to store that example
and if you decide to forget that example
you can never go back and ask for that
example of it
right so so from a kind of practical
standpoint um
you know i mean in reality we're sort of
between these two models and that if you
think of like a big machine learning
application maybe you have a some hard
drive that's really slow full of your
data if you really want you can you know
ask for your same data points back again
but um but maybe that's kind of
expensive and you should think of it
instead as you know you don't plan to
kind of
go back to this
uh
slow big database
you know too many times
any other questions i guess
say the
the celtro versus the
iid data sample setting
this id data sample setting i mean i
should call it kind of the streaming
setting
only um
you know each example is picked
independently from this distribution
that we're defining it's not some
adversarial stream
um
great so in the cell probe model are are
you going to be paying for the accesses
or for the total amount of data like is
that i'm trying to understand if the the
difference is here is just that i'm
allowed to go to the same point twice
but it does cause
cost me twice like you know it's the
same price as if i access two
independent points but i'm sorry gaining
because
it's the same point or is it you're
going to leverage the fact that you can
go back for free
um so it's uh so we will pay for every
access
okay so it costs you to go back
um
although although i guess well
i don't want to split the beans yet but
um
uh but but yeah so so in the cell probe
setting the cost is going to be the
total number of queries we make the
number of
times we access our read-only memory
um
and uh and then in the iid setting
the so cost will be the number of data
points we end up looking at
yeah these are great questions any other
questions on this one
so in the continuous setting um
the sort of analogous problem is as
follows so we're given for the universe
has picked some say unit vector in r to
the d
chosen uniformly at random from the
sphere
and
you know each data point say is a random
unit vector
together with its inner product with the
secret vector x
and here the goal is going to be to you
know to find x or to approximate x say
we want to return a vector whose inner
product with x is at least you know one
minus epsilon
and these um
and the analogous problem in the cell
probe setting is again the sort of the
same thing only now these uh
data points are in some read-only memory
that we can access uh
on demand and in particular like
the first data point never disappears we
can go back and vary it
um
okay and again in the cell probe setting
um you know you can ask well do you get
this data point to infinite precision
are you charged for a bit of the
thing that you asked for um and it's
it's not going to matter too much uh the
details on how you define it
okay
so i should say before going on that
there are many other interesting models
you can think about
in particular models where there's no
direct access to data points but instead
you interact with them via different
sorts of oracles
so for example statistical query access
where you get to dream up functions and
you ask for the expectation of these
functions
over the randomness of your data
distribution
um
in optimization settings you can also
think about things like a function
evaluation
oracle
where
you get to come up with some data point
and you're given the
sort of the loss of this data point
for things like gradient queries and
there's been a lot of work um
so notably lower bounds for learning
tasks under these specific types of um
sort of oracle models
but somehow the you know the more
general setting where we're just asking
no you actually get to see the data
points
and what can you say given different
amounts of memory um there's been sort
of uh
less work in that setting in part
because it's it's more difficult than
proving things for these more restricted
types of data access
okay
okay so we're just going to go through
these um these four squares and say a
little bit about um what's going on
so starting with this
so again the universe has picked a
unknown d-dimensional binary vector
we're given a stream of examples of
random binary vectors and their inner
product with the mystery mod 2 and our
goal is to find this mystery vector
so there are two sorts of obvious
algorithms
so one of them is gaussian elimination
say we take
two times the examples
with all but inverse exponential
probability this linear system over f2
will be um
there will be will be full rank
and so we can just solve this and this
would take um on the order of g squared
memory we
will need on we will need order d
examples and each example is order d
bits
so using order g squared memory we can
just do our gaussian elimination and
solve this linear system over f2
on the other hand one can still solve
this problem with only a linear amount
of memory
by a brute force uh
you know brute force guess and check
so imagine we just iteratively
guess each of the true to the d possible
vectors for x and for each guess we're
going to check
do the next you know 10d examples are
the next 10d examples consistent with
our guess
if they are then probably this guess is
the true x
otherwise we move to the next box
and this this only requires you know d
memory all you need is enough memory to
store the guess x and count up to
um
count up to order d so um
the question is is there anything
between these two so is there
with less than d squared memory can you
still get away with
a linear or polynomial number of
examples
um so in 2015 um with jacob steinhardt
and stefan roger
we had this conjecture that any
algorithm that uses less than d squared
over four memory would end up needing to
see an exponential number of examples to
learn x with any significant probability
of success
um and this was true as proved by ron
ross in in 2016.
um
okay so i'll say a couple words about
how you know about the intuition for why
this is true and about how it's
or how to think about this sort of thing
um but first i should say that there's
um
you know there's been quite a lot of
subsequent work um extending this sort
of result to a broader class of learning
problems over finite fields
and at this point i guess we have
three fairly distinct types of proof for
this sort of result
and you know the proofs of these things
are you know are really beautiful um and
if you if you uh
um you know are interested in this sort
of stuff i i strongly suggest you go to
um mega guards talk which will be on
thursday um talking about some of her
recent work on this
okay so um
intuitively what's going on with this
sort of conjecture
so
yeah how are you possibly going to find
this uh this unknown x
well suppose i give you one data point
then
you know given this data point you say
well before i saw this data point x
could have been any one of these
two to the d possible vectors now that
i've seen this data point that restricts
the possibilities of the true x to some
d minus one dimensional subspace
give it another data point
as long as it's not you know sort of in
the span of the first x
of the first data point um
now your sort of posterior over what the
true x is is well now it could be you
know something in a d minus two
dimensional subspace and so on
so
it seems intuitively like the only way
you can make progress on this problem is
to either keep track of
the sort of subspace span by your
examples
or the subspace in which the the linear
subspace in which the
potential x's exist
and
you know you're starting off where
the
the true x could be anywhere in this d
dimensional linear space
and
intuitively either you keep track of a
basis for the space or you keep track of
a basis for the orthogonal space and
either way you need to kind of go over
this hump in the middle where you're
trying to keep track of
some sort of basis of some
random d over two dimensional subspace
and in that case they have no way of
compressing the basis for such a space
so ron ross's original truth can
formalize this intuition that
your algorithm really needs to be
keeping track of linear subspaces
otherwise it's
it's
kind of uh
almost hopeless anyway and if you're
keeping track of linear subspaces well
there's no way around this pump where
you at some point you need to keep track
of basically a basis of order d
d dimensional vectors which takes
quadratic space
um
okay so
again i guess you know slightly more
so i'm not going to give it
intuition for the proof i just wanted to
give one slide on sort of how to
how to start thinking about these sorts
of questions
which is thinking about memory via
branching programs
so think of a branching program so all
you know your our algorithm is going to
be represented by this branching program
where there's a start state here on the
left
each column of states corresponds to
potential states that our algorithm will
be in after seeing the corresponding
number of examples so after seeing one
example
our
state of our algorithm will be one of
this these
memory states in the first column after
the second example will be one of these
memory states in the second column and
so on
each of these memory states has a
transition function so if we're in this
memory state here
and we see example uh a2 b2
then we'll
then we'll transition to this memories
if we had seen a different example maybe
we transitioned to this memory state
it's also worth mentioning that
there's no point considering randomized
branching programs that they won't be
any more effective
so given this sort of branching program
if we have an algorithm that has at most
k memory then at every time step the
algorithm can be in most true to the k
can be in one of at most two to the k
different memory states
so if you want to have a lower bound
against memory k algorithms it suffices
to argue that any branching program that
solves a problem is going to need to
have at least
the width either at least two to decade
or we'll need to be super long we'll
need to see tons of examples
and again for every uh memory state here
you could ask conditioned on
us arriving at this state
what's the posterior distribution
over possible x's so given that we're
here
what you know which which true x do we
think we started with
and if the algorithm solves the problem
you know by this time with good
probability that must mean that you know
most of these memory states have a
highly peaked posterior
okay
and then the question is just how do you
argue that you either need you know a
wide or a long branching program
okay um
any any quick questions on this
yeah great
so greg i don't know if this is too
eclectic but this is gap between d
square over 20 and d square over four do
you have any speculation about what
happens in between
oh uh yeah the answer is d squared over
four um
but um
yeah so
yeah i don't think it's hopeless kind of
closing this and this 20 uh
uh
it might not actually be 20 i'm not
quite sure what they uh what's proved
but i don't think it shouldn't be so
hard to prove something close to the
right answer is my guess but but uh um
you know and something like d squared
over two you can make like some gaussian
elimination algorithm that's a bit
clever with how it uses the memory to do
that so
okay okay so let me very briefly talk
about what happens in the cell phone
so um in the cell probe setting
suppose we have order d
um examples in this read-only memory
then actually um it turns out that it's
pretty easy to solve this even with just
linear space and a
a polynomial number of queries
and basically this follows from the fact
that there are um no they're nice
circuits they're nice formulas for
um actually any coefficient of the
characteristic uh function of a
of a matrix
so if i give you some formula in terms
of the entries of uh
um
of this read-only memory you don't need
very much you know read write memory to
evaluate this formula because you can
just recompute you know if i want to add
up two
expressions
i can
you know sort of uh
compute this expression and then just
store that number and then compute this
expression from scratch and store that
number and then add these two things up
and store that and so you can just keep
recomputing the parts you need and you
know and use almost no uh um use almost
no memory for this
so um
yeah i i guess this really gets back to
the point uh that someone made earlier
that the key difference between the
cellpro model and this other setting is
that you can
it's really that you can go back and
reuse the same examples and crucially
like the fact that these are the same
examples they're not
sort of
shifting
um
really completely changes the landscape
of this sort of optimization
and in some sense it's fortunate that
this cell pro you know this question in
the cell phone setting is so easy
because
you know in general proving lower bounds
in the cell pro model is sort of
notoriously hard and in many cases it
turns into questions about uh
you know basically equivalent as a you
know p versus np um
you know from the point of lower bounds
um you know often you know these cell
pro model lower bounds turn into
questions of do certain polynomials not
exist which which starts to get very
difficult
in contrast in this iid set
data samples setting
these memory lower bound questions
they're less like p versus np and a bit
more like just information
theoretic
uh questions
and you know in information theory there
are hard problems but there's nothing
like the black hole of p versus np
so um
i guess that was one reason why we're
optimistic about being able to solve
things in this left column whereas in
the right column uh lower bound seem
harder
okay uh let's see do you have five more
minutes or what
five more minutes is good
okay
so let me let me move on to this square
um
so this is sort of analogous question in
the continuous setting
so very briefly um
you know linear regression is obviously
super important from a practical
standpoint
and the sort of broader context is that
from the optimization standpoint um
you know a huge class of optimization
um
the research can be thought of as trying
to find algorithms that in some sense
use only linear memory
while behaving like algorithms that have
that sort of used quadratic memory and
use second order information about the
problem and have um in many cases
significantly uh faster convergence
rates
most of this effort in the optimization
community isn't posed explicitly in
terms of uh memory but i think i think
it's of a helpful perspective to
uh to think of it as just this
can you come up with linear memory
algorithms that behave like you know so
newton-like second-order
algorithms that typically use
quadratically
so
good so let's think about this linear
regression question
the universe has picked a random unit
vector each data point is a random
either unit vector or uh
something drawn from a
isotropic gaussian
and we're given the inner product with
the
hidden vector maybe with some very very
small amount of noise
so here the two extremes are given d
data points
if we store them all and do gaussian
elimination
then we end up using memory d squared
with
say some logarithmic dependence on the
desired accuracy in terms of bit
precision
and we can solve the problem okay so so
d data points for quadratic memory
we can also just do gradient descent we
can do kind of the most optimized
gradient to send the kasmash style
gradient descent
and there we can get away with just
basically linear memory with some
logarithmic dependence on one over
epsilon to keep track of significant
bits
and there um
we end up paying this log one over
epsilon so log log one over the desired
accuracy
and you know there's a question of is
there anything in between is there
anything between you know order d memory
and order d squared memory
so we had this theorem um with uh bottle
um and aaron back in 2019 where we
showed that actually
at least something breaks if you go from
quadratic to subquadratic then namely
that when you go to subquadratic memory
you will need at least some
um you know dependence on this error
you'll need at least
d times log log one over epsilon theta
points okay craig sorry does the
gaussian elimination
d squared log one or epsilon d log one
or f sound makes gradient descent look
strictly better is there is a log one or
epsilon somewhere that it shouldn't be
or am i super confused sorry uh no no so
the number of data points
for gaussian elimination is only d
memory
sorry sorry sorry thank you yeah yeah
sorry right so memory d squared
d data
and you know whereas you know you can uh
pay a log one over epsilon and data
points
and get rid of the d in memory right so
gradient descent looks much better right
if you care at all about memory
but if you care about data then maybe
gaussian elimination isn't
yeah
right so
um to prove that at least something
breaks when you go that you you um you
need at least some you know some
dependence on the error when you go to
sub quadratic memory
um and
it's a bit embarrassing that we can that
we have two logs here and the conjecture
is that you know kind of the
the relatively basic um gradient descent
is optimal for any subquadratic memory
algorithm
so the conjecture is given less than d
squared space
you you need at least d times log one
over epsilon data points
uh without this log log
um and you might say that well you know
like these log one of repsons is this
you know this isn't uh this doesn't
interest me this is kind of you know log
stuff shouldn't matter
and and that's okay um
if
so there's also the so we have the
following conjecture too that says well
if your data is drawn from an
ill-conditioned gaussian an unknown
gaussian with a very high condition
number
um then
actually
you either need enough space to store a
basis for this for this gaussian to
learn and store basis for this
in which case you can just have an
algorithm that has a
poly logarithmic dependence on the
commission number
or if you have subquadratic memory too
little to store a basis for this
gaussian then you're doomed to have a
polynomial dependence on the condition
number
so so this second
conjecture i think is uh is maybe the
more interesting one um and it's
probably also a bit harder
okay just to
very last
comment so
um
in the cell probe model
you um it's definitely worth thinking
about this continuous setting again this
is this is kind of the model in which at
least some
machine learning is happening where you
have a database with your data and if
you want you can ask for the same data
point over and over again
and in this setting um
you know the conjecture that well
yeah
no no no no
the conjecture is that um
uh
you at least need super linear space in
order to solve this problem
however i think this sort of thing might
be extremely hard to prove again because
so cell probe
lower bounds start to look like you know
you're proving that
certain so classes of polynomial don't
exist and this it starts starts looking
much more like p versus
and i guess just a point is that you
could in this continuous cell probe
setting you could still try to apply the
same algorithm as in the discrete cell
probe setting
but there you are doing this kind of
formula in terms of binary things over
f2
and in that case everything is uh you
know you don't need to worry about
arithmetic precision
over the reals when you start to do that
that sort of algorithm where you
recompute all the terms of your formula
as you need them basically you're um
uh
without having at least a polynomial
like precision you end up with um just
arithmetic errors blowing up in your
face
um
so
uh so anyway so so this this bottom
right square i think is actually super
interesting um i know i see this is a
conjecture although uh
it's more of a guess
so i think it might even be worth
thinking about that's an algorithmic
standpoint uh as well as the lower bound
sum
okay so that's
um i guess that's it
let's uh round of applause for greg
[Applause]
since we're running over schedule maybe
we'll do the following i'm going to
stand up here with this with this uh hot
mic and anyone who has questions for
greg maybe we'll keep keep him on the
zoom for a little bit but we'll let
we'll go to the break so that we can
come back on time at 3 40 for the last
session
thanks greg
super nice talk
yeah here's nazi
hey greg hi it's nothing can you see us
actually i don't know
you can't see us so how is this related
to the
i'm trying to figure out the relation
between cell probe and first order
this first order i mean you can
definitely simulate first order with
cell probe but you need to probe the
entire metrics
all right so in cell pro in first order
here you'd get to query specific
specific
specific disease and get back eight a z
right something like that
yeah
sorry for
first order
um
we looked at uh
you know our open problem for
memory limited first order right yeah so
i'm just so i'm trying to figure out how
first order relates to still probe
so in this language first order
corresponds to you can
you can you don't access entries of a
right but you can give me a vector z and
i'll give you a times z yeah right um
right so so again like if you're trying
to
linear
sorry it's sam with with linear
auxiliary space like if i can't i
compute that install probe like like i
just
that will cost you uh
right so the question is whether you
care about
different phone numbers indeed i mean
that would cost you it caused me inquiry
yeah but let's okay that's going to be
so challenging so let's like i don't i
think the point is like you want to
worry about being fine-grained on the
space and you don't want to be worried
about different polynomials indeed right
yeah well but the thing is that the
thing is whether that's more limited or
whether i'm more looking because
you can simulate that with this squared
but
the other way
seems less clear how to simulate maybe
it's also possible
but sorry but yeah with iid data you
know you can also simulate your gradient
things right your idc
what do you mean
so not wait what
nutty what is the model you have in mind
the model you have in mind is you have a
fixed you have a fixed a
ax it's worst case worst case over ax
minus b yeah maybe that is the
difference
see if worst case
i mean the way actually we looked at it
is not for quadratic it's for uh
general convex
but but it's even for quadratic it's
open right so you have a you have a
unknown a and b the b part is is kind of
easy but you have an unknown a and b so
ax minus b you want to solve x uh ax
equals b or minimize you know
x a x minus b uh
whatever means minus b x and you want an
unconditional lower bound on the number
of first order gradient queries exactly
okay
and again remember so we know so the
thing is that here in this case you can
do it with the d log one over epsilon
queries
but for that you need quadratic memory
yeah right with uh
d squared log one over epsilon memory or
you can do it with uh d over epsilon
squared or d over condition number
depending on you know whatever you want
to either right right um
and then you only need linear memory
so one thing sort of between these
models
i didn't talk about is you can also
think about you have this matrix a
but you just get um
yeah you just get random rows
and you know the question is do you need
to pay this extra kind of c factor wait
if you get a random rose what's in this
embed in the iid case
um
so you get random rules but from this
matrix so like if you if you're willing
to raise the case but when you make a
query you don't where you don't say i
would like row i you just say give me a
row and the algorithm gives you a random
do you get do you get the index or not
um because if you don't my guess is if
you don't get if you get the index maybe
you can exploit that if you don't get
the index i would be surprised actually
if that makes it any easier
and because if i don't get the index
yeah yeah you're saying it's no
different than
it doesn't seem so like i don't have a
proof on the top of my head right but it
somehow if i don't get the index
how do i exploit the fact that i might
have seen this row before right i don't
know right my memory
doesn't tell me if i saw this row before
so so i was going to say in the case in
either case say you do know the index
okay now if you know the index then i
can see how that helps you but okay but
then the question would be like
say you go from you know order d data
points
to actually like order you know d square
data points
does the run time get worse because
you're sitting waiting for the same
example to crop up again
yeah
right
yeah that is fine
even if they're given in like a random
order and you know things are kind of
decently conditioned so it's not like
you need to
um
yeah so so um yeah i guess the short
answer i'm not really sure although
uh
i have been thinking a bit about about
your uh your open question tonight and i
think i think we have
like we we have something that's not
really what we would like but we have
sort of some something like what you are
conjecturing oh yes
so but and that's
so you think you can
as in you have the lower bound there
so yeah sort of it's it's not let's see
uh
there's one way in which is not really
what we were hoping for but um because
here you suggested did you think there's
actually a
the possibility of a
positive result in algorithm
but that's probably not implementable
just with the first order you really
need the probes
yeah so right so this is kind of going
via some weird polynomial types right
and that you can you're not going to be
able to implement that with first order
right no no
um but but again like uh
yeah when i say like
there might be an algorithm here like
you know i i don't know
like like
i don't think there is but there might
be some people yeah
all right okay
like
you know proving they you know
polynomials of some form like have this
like weird error correction property
like proving that such polynomials don't
exist sound sounds you know
extremely hard right um but they might
exist because like weird stuff
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna run
out and get some water before the next
session thanks for thanks for the talk
greg super awesome can you not even you
just turn this off
so greg do you think that
i mean do you think that our problem
like with the first order do you think
you get into things that are as hard as
p and p i mean i it somehow still seems
to me that seems to information
theoretically approachable like not have
any idea how to approach it but uh um
yeah i don't know i don't i don't think
so because basically because you know
you can design these instances where
um
um
you can design these instances where
like one example or like one row
of this matrix will like dominate your
gradient up until you sort of uh
you know unless you know it right
like you can you know these convex
problems where like you kind of need to
be
you know orthogonal to all these rows
otherwise
the gradient is just you know the
highest index through that you're not
orthogonal to right
yes
i'm not sure
um
like let's see say i want to be
orthogonal um
like how do you exploit the memory
constraint i mean what you're saying
seems like i could do
i mean that oh you're just
reconstructing
the d log one of reps and lower bound
without memory right but like i'm not
sure how
oh oh no no so basically the claim is
like unless you're filling your memory
with like these rows of the matrix yeah
then you're basically just getting the
same garbage back from the oracle
like if you forget
right but that's it
so maybe we're saying the same thing so
that's an information theoretic argument
that's not like uh
i mean you in the talk you said that
somehow
in the cell probe model that prob you
lose the ability to do simple
information theoretic arguments and then
you resort to things that look like p
not equal to np
i'm wondering what your intuition is for
the first order which sits somewhere in
between them right i mean is that
amenable to
do you feel like that that is amenable
to more information theoretical
approaches
i think so i guess because you can
construct these these examples where
like okay good so we are saying the same
thing okay yeah yeah we're on the same
page so i thought you're saying the
opposite sorry no no no sorry yeah yeah
you can construct example is where the
infer you know kind of the information
in the gradient query like what it's
going to be yeah yeah right or you can
control that yeah
um
yeah okay
thanks i'm going to
go get some snacks okay
yeah i'm going to try to be by a bit
later in the week my my daughter has
like uh like
uh
has a bit of a cold and pence can't go
to daycare um
but if um if that's resolved i'll let's
be good i'm here until wednesday so
you make it before then okay excellent
bye